[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich dich fragen würde an welchen
stars kleinsten die größten spannungen
herrschen welche würdest du mehr nennen
polen und belarus nord und südkorea
indien und pakistan iran und irak
tschechen land und die türkei
aserbaidschan und armenien viele länder
haben schließlich ziemlich lästige
nachbarin und diesem umstand hat es
unter anderem auch diesmal politik zu
verdanken dass uns wohl nie die themen
ausgehen werden also welchen hotspot
nehmen wir uns heute vor nun diesmal
werden wir uns an eine grenze begeben
von der duh in den normalen nachrichten
nie etwas mitbekommt und das vollkommen
zu unrecht denn sie ähnelt wahrlich
einem vulkan einem gewaltigen vulkan
weil jahrzehnte lang schlief inaktiv war
durch keine großen schlagzeilen auffiel
doch in letzter zeit schlagen die
politischen seismologen alarm alle
zeichen deuten darauf hin dass dieser
vulkan nun erwacht sein eruption eine
ganze region verwüstet aschewolke den
himmel jahrzehntelang verdunkelt werden
algerien bericht diplomatische
beziehungen sowie heiko ab da die
spannungen zu nehmen es ist nicht so
dass die beziehungen zwischen den beiden
nachbarn niemals besonders fruchtbar
gewesen wären
[Musik]
die grenze zwischen marokko land gehring
ist seit 1994 geschlossen die beiden
länder sind seit langem wegen der
besetzung der westsahara durch marokko
zerstritten doch in letzter zeit haben
die spannungen weiter zugenommen und der
algerische außenminister beschuldigte
marokko sogar feindliche handlungen zu
begehen und ja ein gewisser weise ist es
typisch für algier rabatt für alles
schlechte verantwortlich zu machen was
ihm wieder fit von der existenz
separatistische gruppen bis hin zu der
brutalen welle von waldbränden die das
land in diesem sommer heimgesucht hat
dieses mal geht ist jedoch um etwas
anderes die frage die wir uns stellen
werden ist also ganz klar was hat
algerien dazu gebracht seine
diplomatischen beziehungen zu marokko
abzubrechen musste es diese entscheidung
wirklich treffen war sich verpasst so
schlecht benommen hat besteht die gefahr
dass die dinge aus dem ruder laufen und
die marokkaner und algerier in einem
krieg aufeinander losgehen und was hat
das alles mit der erdgasversorgung
europas zu tun nun selbstverständlich
werden wir heute all diese fragen
beantworten woher briesen wir euch aber
noch mit ein wenig werbung für unsere
lieben spor song serve schacht libyen
der start ist ein wiki in welches
sicherheit und anonymität nicht auf die
leichte schulter nimmt es lockt wie der
datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten und bringt außerdem
jede menge security tools mit cirque ist
aber auch aus vielen anderen gründen ein
ganz tolles vbm natürlich könnt ihr mit
dessen hilfe auf websites und in der
dienste zugreifen die in dem land in dem
ihr gerade seid nicht verfügbar sind
ohne zensur und walking ob daheim oder
im urlaub darüber hinaus bietet es
jedoch weitere sicherheits-features habt
ihr nicht zum beispiel auch ein mulmiges
gefühl durch die allgegenwärtigen werbe
popups und cookies mit surft bekommt ein
handliches tool namens green web dass
die alle bloggt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt aber
nicht nur das mit nur einem server
contro könnt ihr alle eure geräte eben
vpn registrieren handys notebooks oder
sogar ihren smart tvs deckt wirklich
alle arten von geräten ab wie ihr
bekommt damit einen lückenlosen schutz
so und weil wir euch unsere treuen fans
solid haben haben wir nur bereiche
sponsoring zu übernehmen wenn euch
surfer hat auch einen ordentlichen
rabatt eingeräumt und das ist uns
gelungen mit hilfe des rabattcodes
predigt de bekommt ihr sage und schreibe
83 prozent rabatt und obendrein noch die
ersten vier monate gratis dazu denn
links zu diesem angebot findet ihr in
der beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besonderes service- und
hätte damit gleichzeitig auch ist damit
für euch weiterhin so informative videos
wie dieses liefern können hier ist aber
ganz schnell in die sahara und zwar mit
einem kurzen blick in die geschichte
[Musik]
die vergessenen düne
algerien und marokko haben sich noch nie
besonders gut verstanden beide länder
betrachten sich selbst gerne als die
dominierende großmacht des maghreb das
geht natürlich irgendwie nicht und diese
rivalität führt deswegen immer wieder zu
reibereien
erschwerend kommt hinzu dass beide
länder eine 1600 kilometer lange grenze
teilen eine grenze die frankreich der
frühere kolonialherr nie allzu genau
ziehen wollte so dass die grenze
zwischen den beiden ländern unscharf
blieb eines der ersten dinge die beide
länder taten sobald sie ihre
unabhängigkeit erlangt hatten war immer
mehr truppen an die grenze zu schicken
um ihre jeweiligen territorien zu
erweitern und so begann der sogenannte
sand krieg 963 kam es zu zahlreichen
grenzkonflikte welche die rivalität
feindschaft zwischen den beiden nachbarn
nur weiter anheizen
[Musik]
seitdem war der hauptkonfliktpunkte
immer die ehemalige spanische provinz
west sahara im jahr 1975 besetzte
marokko dieses gebiet mit dem so
genannten grünen marsch und innerhalb
weniger monate braucht ein krieg
zwischen den invasoren und der
unabhängigkeits fraktionen der polisario
front aus und trotz der materiellen
unterstützung durch algerien ist die
wahrheit dass die kämpfe für die
interessen der sahara es überhaupt nicht
gut verliefen die truppen von hassan dem
zweiten zögerten keine sekunde napalm
und weißem phosphor einzusetzen die
sahara ist wurden zu flüchtlingen in
algerischen flüchtlingslager
seitdem leben 180.000 sachau ist in der
provinz den duft einer riesigen wüste
ebene mitten in der sahara
der krieg zwischen marokko und der
polisario dauerte an bis 1989 ein
waffenstillstand erreicht vor bedankt
der vermittlung der uno und der
vereinbarung zwischen beiden parteien
ein referendum abzuhalten das problem
ist nur dass dieses referendum
abgehalten wurde und wahrscheinlich auch
nie abgehalten werden wird der punkt ist
dass der waffenstillstand 1989 als
chance den markt gesehen wurde der punkt
ist aber dass der waffenstillstand 1989
als chance für den markt abgesehen wurde
denn genau zu diesem zeitpunkt wurde die
ah mu die arabische margret union eine
organisation zur förderung des
freihandels zwischen algerien die
bethanien rocco und tunesien gegründet
und wisst ihr was sie war ein sofortiger
erfolg die kleinsten wurden geöffnet und
die visa kontrollen wurden aufgehoben
der handel konnte frei von einem land
zum anderen verkehren aber die harmonie
war nur von kurzer dauer sie hielt kaum
fünf jahre ein bürgerkrieg sturz der
algerien ist chaos und alle hoffnungen
welche in die eu gesetzt wurden und
plötzlich zunichte gemacht
1994 drei bewaffnete männer in das hotel
atlas einem rasch ein und töteten zwei
spanische touristen was dann der zweite
beschuldigte algerien hinter dem
anschlag zu stecken woraufhin rock pop
es nicht tausende algerische einwohner
und touristen ausliest und erneut dieser
verlangte die algerischen generäle
reagierten mit der befestigung und
schließung der grenzen
[Musik]
seitdem sind fast 30 jahre vergangen und
während dieser ganzen zeit war die
grenze geschlossen jahrelang wurde die
algerische wirtschaft durch die
förderung von öl und gas angekurbelt das
land verfügt über die ressourcen um
seine entwicklung zu finanzieren
doch mit dem verfall der preise für
fossile brennstoffe stürzte algerien
wieder ins chaos vor allem seit den
volks protesten im jahr 2019 die boote
fliegers 20-jährige diktatur beendeten
[Musik]
inzwischen hat marokko seine position
gestärkt tatsächlich ist ist die al
arabi dynastie die das größte interesse
an der wiedereröffnung der grenzen
gezeigt hat mohammed der sechste sagte
dies im vergangenen juli in seiner
thronrede
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass eine
offene grenze zwischen zwei benachbarten
ländern und zwei brüderlichen völkern
die norm ist die schließung von grenzen
ist unvereinbar mit einem natürlichen
recht und einem grundlegenden
rechtsprinzip die beide in
internationalen takten verankert und
einschließlich des vertrags von
marrakesch welcher der gründungs text
der union des arabischen maghreb
[Musik]
wie dem auch sei es sieht nicht danach
aus als würde sich diese situation in
nächster zeit ändern worauf läuft das
ganze also hinaus wird ist genau hin
denn höchstwahrscheinlich werden wir in
zukunft leider mehr schlechte dinge aus
diesem pool fast zu sehen bekommen
[Musik]
neuer spannungen und alte streitigkeiten
es ist fast ein jahr her dass die
polisario frau den waffenstillstand mit
marokko beendet hat der für ruhe in der
wester haare gesorgt hatte die situation
verschlechterte sich als die vereinigten
staaten die marokkanische souveränität
über die ehemalige spanische provinz
anerkannten tross entscheidung war ein
sieg für die alawiten ost ii und einen
schlag gegen die beschreibungen der
sahara ist eines tages ein referendum
über die unabhängigkeit abhalten zu
können im gegenzug musste marokko seine
diplomatischen beziehungen zu israel
normalisieren und wenn wir von
normalisierung sprechende von
transparenz wenn die wahrheit ist dass
israel und marokko immer sehr herzliche
beziehungen unterhalten haben wenn auch
nicht offiziell eine vorschau auf zu der
vielleicht auf die nutzung der
israelischen spionage-software pegasus
durch die marokkanischen behörden gehört
projekt picassos algerien wird von
marokko genau beobachtet algerien
beschuldigt den marokkanischen
geheimdiensten mit der pegasus software
6000 telefon nummern ausgespäht zu haben
aber wir reden hier nicht von
irgendwelchen beliebigen 6000
telefonnummern die rede ist von fast
allen bonzen im nachbarland den
sogenannten lepro war der politischen
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen elite
rallye algerien seit der unabhängigkeit
des landes beherrscht bestreitet das
alles ab und führt deswegen auch
gerichtsverfahren den machthabern all
hier ist das aber egal wieder mal können
sie ihre bad beschuldigen und zu allem
überfluss noch der spionage in
zusammenarbeit mit israel zumindest
halten sie es für die perfekte
propaganda message denn algerien ist ein
land in dem sich alles sehr sehr langsam
bewegt ist man merkt wie die uhren
mittlerweile dicken ist auch der letzte
zug abgefahren und deswegen erweist sich
also auch heute noch als einer der
engagiertesten verfechter der
sogenannten
palästinensischen sache algier wirft
rabatt also vor die muslimische welt zu
verraten den nehme es sich mit dem
jüdischen verbündet
in tel aviv holt man da schon mal das
popcorn die logik von der feind meines
feindes ist mein freund funktioniert
immer vor drei jahren brach rabatt auch
die beziehungen zum iran ab nachdem
bekannt wurde dass die polisario front
vom iran und der hisbollah unterstützt
wird die fronten scheinen also geklärt
zu sein marokko und israel gegen
algerien und den iran deshalb besuchte
der israelische premierminister im
august marokko und ließ sich die
gelegenheit nicht entgehen noch ein
wenig mehr öl ins feuer zu gießen rapid
enthüllt die existenz einer annäherung
zwischen algerien und dem iran aber seid
vorsichtig denn all diese erneuten
beziehungen zwischen arques und israel
kommen auch der algerischen regierung
gelegen wie die bereitschaft da hat der
rückgang der öl- und gaspreise im
vergangenen jahr die wirtschaft des
landes schwer getroffen vor allem weil
die regierung viele dinge mit den
einnahmen aus dem öl- und gasgeschäft
revolutioniert hat und sobald die
kürzungen bei ihnen ankamen haben die
proteste der bürger das regime von
bouteflika zum sturz gebracht foto
flickr hat als staatschef über jahre
viele milliarden us-dollar an staatsgeld
außer landes bringen lassen aber freut
sich nicht zu früh denn die post gute
flieger zeit ist noch schlimmer
um die macht im land bekämpfen und
verschiedene fraktionen der sogenannten
lebte war vielen macht elite und der des
titel der militärischen entscheider die
der machtkämpfe haben das chaos im land
nur noch ausgeweitet ein äußerer feind
marokko oder israel in den mittelpunkt
zu rücken ist daher eine strategie
welche die algerische propaganda gerne
in anspruch nimmt und in welchem ausmaß
nur in dem maße in dem sich nord
algerien in diesem sommer buchstäblich
in den inferno verwandelte und marokko
bot zwei löschflugzeuge an aber was
denkst du was die algerische antwort
darauf war nun lieber verbrennen sein
gesicht zu verlieren
marokkos angebot an algerien stößt auf
taube ohren die bohnen ruf nach
europäischer hilfe aber glaubt mehr
damit ging das menschenverachtende
tauziehen erst so richtig los denn klar
ist dass die volkswirtschaften beider
länder viel gewinde und wenn beide
länder gut miteinander auskämen und die
dinge herangehen laufen sicherlich nicht
in die richtige richtung besonders wenn
es um die wirtschaft geht die frage ist
also warum ist in algier so viel
interesse an der konfrontation mit
rabatt gibt ist ist nur eine frage der
propaganda und des politischen
marketings nun auch gepasst
gaskrieg im mittelmeer
algerien ist der zehntgrößte
erdgasproduzent der welt die hälfte
dieses gases wird für den eigenen
verbrauch verwendet die andere hälfte
wird exportiert wir vorstellen kannst du
die hauptabnehmer europäische länder
heute 60 prozent des erdgases aus
algerien ins ausland verkauft gelangt
über pipelines nach italien oder spanien
aber du weißt jetzt natürlich wo
algerien liegt damit diese den
europäischen kontinent erreichen konnten
war es daher notwendig mit den
nachbarländern zu verhandeln tunesien
ist für die trans mittelmeer gaspipeline
und marokko für die macht europa
pipeline und ja die aktuelle
diplomatische krise zwischen den beiden
ländern hat bereits folgen neue
eskalation algerien stellt
gaslieferungen nach spanien über marokko
ein wenn es etwas gibt was die
volkswirtschaften von algerien und
marokko miteinander verbindet dann ist
es zweifellos die macht trap europa
gaspipeline insgesamt 1400 kilometer
pipeline führen von den algerischen
filtern nach cordoba in spanien 450 km
davon verlaufen durch marokkanisches
gebiet bevor sie die straße von
gibraltar überqueren die pipeline wurde
1996 eingeweiht und hat derzeit eine
transportkapazität von rund zehn
milliarden kubikmetern erdgas pro jahr
die verhandlungen für die realisierung
dieser pipeline begann 1990 also genau
in der fünfjährigen periode in der sich
marokko algerien einigermaßen gut
verstanden es war ein win win win
abkommen spanien sicherte sich seine
hauptquelle für die gasversorgung
während algerien durch den handel
erreicht wurde aber der eigentliche
schlüssel liegt darin was die
marokkanische allawi dynastie davon
hatte
als gegenleistung für die transitrechte
erhält nach chur ein abgabe von sieben
prozent des wertes des über diese route
exportierten gases im jahr 2009 10 kamen
so auf grund der gesunkenen
rohstoffpreise nicht mal 50 millionen
euro bei aber wer 2014 betrugen die
transitgebühren noch satte 200 millionen
euro außerdem wird die pipeline von
einem unternehmen betrieben an dem die
spanische netz ag und die produktive
aufgrund einer vereinbarung aus dem jahr
1992 die am 31 oktober 2021 ausläuft
gemeinsam beteiligt sind das bedeutet
dass der marokkanische abschnitt der
pipeline erst vor wenigen tagen wieder
in den besitz des amerikanischen staates
übergegangen ist krabat hatte bereits
verlauten lassen ist hoffe ein noch
vorteilhafteren abkommen zu erhalten das
problem für marokko ist das die macht
hat europa pipeline nicht die einzige
ist über die algerisches gas auf die
iberische halbinsel transportiert wird
im jahr 2011 wurde die unterwasser
gaspipeline mit gas eingeweiht die die
algerischen gasfelder direkt mit dem
spanischen almeria verbindet sie hat
allerdings nur eine kapazität von 8
milliarden kubikmetern pro jahr das
bedeutet dass die mit gas pipeline
allein nicht ausreichen würde um
spaniens bedarf zu decken aber algeriens
staatsunternehmen sonatrach unternimmt
bereits erste schritte um dem abzuhelfen
lg und sony tranche erweitern die
kapazität der mit gas pipeline um 25
prozent der auslauf und matt gas wird
die export kapazität der pipeline auf
zehn milliarden kubikmeter erhöhen gemäß
der vereinbarung sieht ganz fix bis ende
2021 fertiggestellt sein und algerien
hat spanien von den fall dass sich das
projekt verzögert oder noch mehr gas
benötigt wird sogar zugesichert dass es
bereit wäre es der schiff mit flüssig
erdgas zu versorgen
[Musik]
ein weiteres problem für marokko ist
dass die macht europa pipeline 45
prozent des gasbedarfs des landes zu
einem preis unterhalb des marktpreises
deckt erdgas für jene der kraftwerke die
zwölf prozent des strom des landes
erzeugen mit anderen worten mit dem
zudrehen des fans der macht werde europa
gaspipeline dreht algerien seinen
nachbarn eine wichtige energie und
einnahmequelle ab
das beste werkzeug für politische
propaganda obwohl es nicht das einzige
ist die wahrheit ist dass man in algier
in letzter zeit keine gelegenheit
auslässt ich über seinen nachbarn lustig
zu machen das schüren von konflikten
gegen einen äußeren feind ist eben ein
typisches mittel sollen politikern auf
der ganzen welt um von ihrem eigenen
versagen abzulenken und ihrer macht zu
vergrößern
algerien sperrt den luftraum für alle
marokkanischen flugzeuge es gibt jedoch
zwei probleme die algerien nicht
ignorieren sollte
einerseits ist die lieferung von energie
teurer als die von gas das über
pipelines angeliefert wird daher wird
das algerische gas einen battle ass
vorteil verlieren und die spanischen
registrierungs anlagen können nicht nur
energie aus algerien sondern auch aus
anderen teilen der welt beziehen sie
müssen also aufpassen dass der ausbau
der pipeline nicht verzögert wird
andererseits wurde algerien um die macht
europa gaspipeline keine alternative für
den transport seines ärgers ist auf die
iberische halbinsel haben wenn die met
gaspipeline aufgrund eines technischen
problems nicht in betrieb genommen
werden kann
damit würde das land eine seiner
wichtigsten einnahmequelle verlieren
außer dem markt spanien über gasvorräte
verfügen die vorübergehend einen
versorgungsengpass ausgleichen können
aber ich versichere dir das in den
algerischen kasten im moment kein
einziger die name übrig ist ganz zu
schweigen von dem geld das sie verlieren
würden wenn sie in marokko nicht mehr
beliefern könnten
[Musik]
die internationalen anleihemärkten
äußerst algerisch da ich mal allergisch
auf jede art von einer ausfällen
reagieren kursverluste für algerische
staatsanleihen und ein rasanter anstieg
der zinsen für seine schulden wären die
folge letztendlich deutet alles darauf
hin dass diese enormen spannungen
zwischen den beiden nachbarn nur ein
trick algeriens sind um seine position
bei den verhandlungen über die zukunft
der bahn fährt europa partei zu stärken
und naoko daran zu hindern eine
überarbeitung der vor 30 jahren
vereinbarten bedingungen zu fordern aber
natürlich man weiß nie wenn es derartige
spannungen gibt reicht ein kleiner
fehler das kleinste missverständnis und
plötzlich brennt die lunte mit dem feuer
zu spielen das heißt mit
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen
drohungen carlo kann schon nach hinten
losgehen aber an dieser stelle haben wir
eine frage an dich glaubst du dass es am
ende die verlusten wird und eine
einigung erzielt wird die sowohl für
marokko als auch für algerien von
vorteil ist welche rolle spielt dabei
europa und seine gasversorgung wie immer
freuen wir uns auf eure meinung zu
diesem thema im kommentarbereich und ich
hoffe also dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat fast jahr gibt es bei
deinen like dass sie mit euren freunden
und vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen
um keines unserer videos mehr zu
verpassen nach gut und bis bald
[Musik]